the turkish city of gaziantep 70
kilometers from the border with syria
hosts about half a million syrian
refugees
it has been more than a decade since war
forced them to leave their homes to make
a new life
now they face the possibility of having
to move again
every day i have this fear of being
deported when my child goes to school i
worry when my wife goes shopping i have
anxiety we can't exercise even our
fundamental rights a thief broke my car
window two weeks ago and stole
everything inside a lawyer advised me
not to report it to the police because i
might be deported
any official complaint might lead a
syrian to being deported deported to
wear a warzone
presidential elections are due to take
place in turkey next year during
president recep tayyip erdogan's tenure
the country has taken in about four
million syrian asylum seekers but with
the economy faltering so too is public
support for them some opposition parties
are capitalizing on the anti-refugee
sentiment and promising to send syrians
back if they win
to counter this the ruling party has
launched a diplomatic push to improve
relations with the syrian government
syrians however worried the worst is yet
to come
after numerous attempts we found some
people willing to talk to us they have
asked that we protect their identities
saying although they want their voices
to be heard they are afraid of being
deported
is from aleppo he says his two brothers
are in prison back in syria he hasn't
heard from them in years and hopes they
are still alive
he didn't want to be filmed in public in
case the camera drew attention to him
deportations have become systematic and
frequent the recent statements from
turkish officials make us worry that we
could be sent back at any minute if i'm
deported to the regime controlled areas
i'll have the same fate as my brothers
if i'm deported to idlib radical groups
will not let us have a life
assassinations and bombardment are all
that wait for us there
on the other side of the border in syria
the ongoing war is silencing syrians
voices on this side of the border in
turkey the fear of being deported is
forcing them to stay quiet
syrians say neither country is safe for
them anymore
al jazeera gaziantep turkey